these are confirmations for doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness but
first do me a favor subscribe
notifications i am doing this every day
rob liefeld the co-creator for deadpool
has officially said that a lot of the
rumors and leaks are true he's been
doing a lot of interviews lately and
he's being very forward with his
answering for now it looks like he is
confirming the leaks of certain cameos
on what rumors exactly it is not
entirely clear but i am excited because
there are some crazy rumors out there
that i hope are true
so far some of the cameos that i heard
are patrick stewart hugh jackman tom
cruise even john krasinski coming as a
variant of reed richards from the
fantastic four again if you haven't
already do me a favor please hit
subscribe turn on notifications i am
doing this every day i'm bringing you
those mcu
news updates rumors theories reviews
it's gonna be a fun journey here i am
just getting started so stick around and
i'll see you tomorrow